Well Ron, thank you for
coming. Today we're delighted
to have mister overexposure,
uh,
at Google.
He is the senior fellow at the Center
for American progress where he writes
about education, uh, and founded the
center science of learning initiative.
He's here today to discuss his third
book titled to learn better mastering the
skills for success in life,
business in school,
or how to become an expert
in just about anything.
Please join me in welcoming Mr [inaudible]
[inaudible].
So I'm up here cause I wrote a book on
the science of learning and it's gotten
some nice attention,
has been featured on NPR and the
Atlantic wired scientific American.
And it makes it pretty simple argument.
For a long time we've assumed that
the ability to learn was a matter of
intelligence, right? Sort of
raw smarts, intellectual power,
sort of cognitive horsepower.
And this is what Iq tests are
really supposed to measure. Uh,
your ability to reason through
new problems to acquire expertise,
but we know now, right, is that we
can get much better at learning,
right?
And there's specific tools and strategies
that allow us to acquire expertise at
much greater rates.
And in this way, right?
We can think about the skill of
learning to learn really as a way to
artificially improve
our, uh, intelligence.
So I first got interested in this
topic as a little kid. That's me.
And I really had a hard
time learning in school. Uh,
was in special education.
I repeated kindergarten,
I had one experience that I
talked about in the book where,
you know,
it was a 45 minute class and math and
I managed to be unable to read my own
handwriting. Uh, I cheated
off my neighbor, you know,
eventually I acquired some of
the skills of, of learning. Uh,
some just sort of came to you as,
as came to me as they come to too
many of us over time, you know,
started thinking about thinking.
But this is really what sparked my
interest in learning overall. Right? Uh,
and since for the past, like
20 years or so, on and off,
I've been writing and
researching about education.
So we're gonna start a
little bit with some quizzes.
We're going to have a lot of quizzes.
What's the capital of Australia?
So I had this question posed to me.
Um, and it was embarrassing, right?
It was like a researcher, a was posing
the question to me and I was like,
I should know the answer to
this. Right? And you know,
I thought Sydney first, I was
wrong. Melborne I was wrong.
The answer is c as we have some
folks here who, who mentioned it.
Um, so I'm going to up the ante
a little bit here since you know,
you guys knew quickly,
or at least some of you knew the
answer to the of us Julia to um,
the Immaculate Conception,
right?
So the question here is what is the
immaculate conception revolve around here?
My first answer was a, was a Jesus, right?
I mean that's sort of the
popular conception and I'll
acknowledge here at the
front end that this idea is,
is you know,
specific to Christianity and
within a cultural context,
but it turns out right
to the answer is right.
The immaculate conception actually stage
is all about married is not about about
Jesus. So researchers call this
the hyper correction effect.
And what's interesting about it is the
more confident you are in your answer and
then you're shown to be wrong,
the more likely you are to have learned
and to retain that information into the
future,
right?
And so what I find interesting about this
is that I think a lot of people think
about learning and sort of think about
the brain like hits a computer, right?
There is data out there and the data
sort of comes to you and maybe process it
and you put it into little boxes,
right? But if that were true, right,
if the brain function in that way, you
wouldn't have a hyper correction effect,
right? I mean error is, would mean
that you're actually not learning.
But what we see from something like
this is actually the more wrong that you
think that the, the more wrong than you
are, right? The actually more that you,
that you learn. And so when we
think about this, you know, and,
and this kind of brings us to this sort
of first lesson is that learning is
sense making, right? That it is,
our brain is not like a computer.
And we have to make sense of the material,
right?
And a lot of research makes this true.
And it also helps us think a little
bit about certain study strategies.
So over the past 10 years we've seen a
wealth of evidence show that some really
common study strategies, common tools for
people to learn aren't that effective.
So rereading right, not that
effective highlighters, right?
Which we see in like office
buildings and schools. I work, uh,
often in a law library.
You know,
not only do these students
have lots of highlighters,
they have different colored highlighters,
right?
And I didn't really want him
to go to them and be like,
there's actually no research
behind. Behind those. Right?
Underlying is the same thing.
So on the other side,
so what is sort of sense making,
right?
And examples of that is something
like self explaining, right?
Which is sort of really
a form of quizzing,
which is why we're going to have a lot
of quizzes as a, you know, I'm talking,
I'm up here and you know,
this is an example.
This is a guy named Brian Ross.
He was a professor for a long time
at the University of Illinois.
He got an opportunity to take an
artificial intelligence, a class.
And you can imagine,
right?
He took it with other undergraduates and
he knew very immediately like, you know,
he stood out, right? He's
sort of older, balding,
but he really wants you
to do well in this class.
And so what he did was just engage in
a lot of self explaining basic ideas.
This right at the end of a page,
at the end of the paragraph,
at the end of the sentences to explain
to yourself what exactly you're learning.
The approach shows a lot of effectiveness
in the research and for, you know,
Brian Ross himself,
you know,
he wasn't able to code as well as some
of the other students that had a lot more
prior knowledge. Um, but he was
able to learn a lot more in many.
He actually just simply understood a
lot more than the other other students.
And when we think about
learning a sense making,
right as a way of sort of
actively engaging material,
you know, another thing,
uh, make sense is explaining something to
other people. So researchers, you know,
really loved to name things
specific in psychology.
This is now known as the protege effect,
right?
And explains why explaining something to
someone else is actually like a really
effective way to learn.
So an example of this is Richard Fineman
might be familiar to many of you.
One of the most well known
successful physicist, um, you know,
sort of the modern times.
And he once had his boss,
the provost at Caltech can
come to him and was like, look,
I'm not entirely sure sort of
how half particles, uh, a bay,
uh, this form of direct
statistics. And finally was like,
okay, you know, I'm
going to figure this out.
I'm going to explain it to a bunch of
freshmen, comes back a few weeks later,
he's like,
I can't actually explain this to them.
And that means we don't
really understand it.
So I really just want to make clear that,
you know,
testing yourself is a really fantastic
way to learn is a study done by Jeff
Carr. Picky. And what you can see here
is, you know, you see the study once,
this is what many of us did
in college, right? You get
some text, you read it once,
and then you take a test.
Okay.
Repeated study is sort of the
more dilligent college students.
They read the text once
and then they're like, oh,
I should probably read it again. So
they read it a second time, right?
So you can see how they do concept
mapping might be familiar to many of you,
right? But this idea that you're
trying to create relationships, right?
So a spokes and hubs, um, so we see that,
uh, doesn't do quite as
well as repeated study. Uh,
and then you see retrieval practice.
So retrieval practices of the word that
psychologists use for this idea that you,
you're just pulling things out of memory.
So what these students did was simply
to have an open piece of paper and they
were told to recall the information that
they had just read. And as you can see,
they did much better than
than the other students.
So we're going to go here to another quiz.
This idea is related to the
first and the question is,
do you block your practice
or do you mix your practice?
So to put this in another way, would
you, if you are playing the piano,
do all Mozart on one day all back on
the next day and then a little Chopin on
the third day, right? Or in each
study session, do you mix it up?
Right? So in each study
session, each practice session,
do you do a little Mozart,
a little Chopin? Um, so I'm just going to
do a little sort of random calling you.
What do you think mixed approach,
blocked approach, mixed approach.
It's a mixed approach
is the correct answer.
Most students choose the sort of blocked
approach. The reason that this works,
right? It's actually kind of similar to
learning a sense sensemaking right? It,
it actually prevents you from bullying
to robotic in the way that that you
practice. So this brings us to our
second lesson. You got to mix it up
for me.
I found this really fascinating and it
gets it sort of as this bigger issue is
sort of doing something,
it's not learning right.
You don't actually get better simply by
doing something for, you know, for myself.
A great example is driving.
I've been driving since I'm 18
I have not gotten any better.
Handwriting's pretty similar
to me. I've been, you know,
writing things right every day and I
have not gotten better since sort of,
you know,
middle school.
So I also play a lot of basketball and
my wife and kids were away and it was
just very apparent to me that I was
like one of the worst guys, you know,
out on the basketball court too.
I took lessons with this guy.
He's played for the Harlem Globe.
Trotters name was Dwayne.
What was impressive to me is one, I
just, I got a lot better, not great,
but a lot better, you know,
just with like two sessions.
And it was kind of crazy to
me cause I was like, you know,
I've been writing about education for
like 20 years and still I was sort of
skeptical about, you know, the power of
these very basic things like feedback.
And then I started to sort of get a
lot more into the sort of science of,
of learning was like, Oh, you know,
I should really then use
interleaving in my own life.
It showed impressive effects.
What's remarkable about this is that
this has been documented since like the
1970s. It's been documented
across different subject areas.
It's even been documented in basketball
and the study from like 1972 with a,
a group of female basketball players.
But I've little kids at home, right.
And they, uh, you know,
one of them is eight,
she's studying her division
timestables and you know how they are,
they come home when she studies
at eight time table on one day.
She studies her nine times
table, the, you know, next week.
And it's just a very clear example
that we really just don't do enough to
interleave to mix up
the way that we learn.
The other thing that's interesting
about interleaving, right, is that one,
it needs to be in the same subject here,
right?
If you're trying to get better at
knitting, it won't necessarily, you know,
you're not going to interleave with sort
of coding or diving or whatever else
you want to learn,
but the,
the other reason that interleaving is
so powerful is that it allows us to
understand what's called the deep feature,
right?
The deep features is really what you want
to learn when you're learning and when
you varied the surface features,
right?
You're going to understand what that basic
idea is and that allows you to engage
in, in sort of pattern recognition.
A very simple example of this, right,
is that you want to learn four plus
four one way would be to do it in,
in mathematical notation. You can change
the surface future's pretty easily by,
you know, doing it in a word problem,
right? Johnny comes into a school,
he has four and you can see,
right,
we're into leaving in that way will
produce these, these much, uh, greater,
greater effects. This is
another quiz, quiz question,
but moment for you guys to
read it over.
So sir, uh, you guesses. So
I'm in, the key thing is to
commit to an answer, right?
We knew from the hyper correction effect
that the more that you commit to an
answer, the more that you're
actually going to learn. So you know,
me just sort of randomly
calling on people as in me,
it'd be an effort as much as you know,
were you on all gain a little
bit more from this? Yeah.
D all of the above,
right?
This is a very key idea here and that
is a context really matters, right? It,
this could really be from
all of the above, right?
And the context in which that you read
that is really going to change the way
that you're going to understand that
material. So it's gets us to lesson three,
right? You need to think
about your thinking, right?
And researchers call this
something called metacognition.
And it kind of appears in in two different
ways. One is sort of planning, right?
And when you're thinking about your
thinking, you're thinking like,
will I understand this? What are
the goals that I need to accomplish?
How am I actually going to measure what
I know? Right? And then the other is,
is sort of monitoring, right? And is this
idea right that we are sort of, you know,
do I really understand this?
Does this come from a dishwasher manual
or is this really sort of a, uh, you know,
from,
from a patent.
And the key thing to understand here
is that we're all overconfident. Okay.
If you do surveys and people,
most people say that they are above
average when it comes to driving.
Most people say that they above average,
you know, when it comes to looks,
most people are above average.
When you asked them, you know,
do they work harder than their coworkers?
Right?
But we know that everyone
can be above average. Nope.
Lots has been written about the sort of
idea of overconfidence is sort of like a
key, a notion of behavioral economics.
But when it comes to learning,
it's really important,
right?
Because our goal is actually to really
understand and there's so many things,
right,
that we actually think that we know,
but we don't really know is that Mr to
me all the time it's happened to me,
you know, like once a month.
Most recently, you know,
my kids went to Gettysburg and I was like,
Oh yeah,
I learned about that and I could maybe
get through sort of what would be like
the first paragraph on like the
Gettysburg, you know, website.
But then when they ask like any reasonable
question, you know, who was the,
you know, general for
the, you know, north,
I assume we had had no idea and
fluency plays a big role in this.
The more that you're familiar with
something and you might not, you might,
you might think that you know a lot
about it, right? Uh, but you end up not,
which is explains why,
like a lot of people think
that they really know how
it toilet bowl works, right?
Spend a lot of time until the bowls.
But if I were to ask you,
and certainly most people and maybe here,
right,
really explained the what the engineering
that goes behind the toilet bowl is,
it's hard for, for most of us, the
second and aspect of metacognition,
right, is, is monitoring, right? And
it's sort of an ancillary to the idea of,
of feedback, right? Which is
why Twain, Samuel's my, um,
basketball coach was so
effective and you know,
really is this idea of it.
You're actually paying attention to,
to what you're doing, right? I don't
pay enough attention to driving,
which explains why I
am not a better driver.
I clearly don't pay enough
attention to my handwriting,
which explains why I haven't
gotten better at that.
But even just a little bit of
monitoring can go incredibly far away.
Uh, my favorite example here is,
is a guy, a neurosurgeon in Canada,
and what he did was something very
simple. He, for every surgery that he had,
he would just write down
what went wrong, right?
So if he dropped a scalpel
and make a note of it,
if you miscommunicated to a nurse,
you'd note that too.
And he found tremendous
improvements in his performance,
not only over the first year that he
did it, but over a period of 10 years.
The other thing about this
type of monitoring is,
and really feedback in general
is that it's embarrassing, right?
So whether I go to see a basketball
coach and I'm in my forties and basically
all of his other clients are like
little kids. Like that's embarrassing.
I didn't actually really tell most of
the people that I took the basketball
lessons with.
The neurosurgeon hadn't even,
I frankly think of much more
embarrassing experience.
He ended up dropping someone's skull
during the surgery about a size of
someone's call about the size of a quarter
and then had to go to that family and
be like, Oh, I'm, you know,
I'm really sorry I dropped a
piece of your husband's skull.
And he describes that as mortifying.
And I think it helps us understand like
why we don't engage in enough monitoring,
why we don't engage in enough of feedback.
Okay.
So we have another quiz question here.
Give you guys a moment to,
uh,
look at it.
So
when to give it a shot.
See,
so more than five items for a long time,
people believe that c
was the right answer.
A lot of early research on
this idea was, uh, you know,
seven items plus or minus a one or two.
It turns out that his research that was
done in the 1950s what researchers know
now it's this much closer to
three to five items. Okay.
So we're going to talk about in this quick
lesson and sort of remembering memory
and what we're going to talk
about first is short term memory.
If we're going to go to the next slide.
Yeah,
looks like we're not going
to go to the next slide.
But what is important about this idea?
Short term memory is really, really small.
It's smaller than most people
believe that it's going to be right.
So this helps us understand like why
it's so hard to remember phone numbers,
right? For a long time. The
telephone companies, you know,
when they first rolled
out telephone numbers,
they did it with a mix of
address and a mix of numbers.
He would have something like a
Elmwood nine three five right?
Then the research came out by Herbert
Simon and others 1950s and they knew it's,
it's you know, seven digits, right?
So this would be a number like four,
seven to 60, 78. Right?
And now it's clear that the telephone
companies realize that short term memory
is even than that.
Right?
Which is why numbers that you really
need to remember or like nine one,
one and three, one one. So why is this
important besides telephone numbers?
Is that everything you learn,
right? Knitting, diving,
driving.
It all goes through short term memory.
And the thing is that short term memory
is so short that we can't hold a lot in
it and this helps us really understand
a lot of other things about learning,
right? It explains why educators
are so important, right?
You want something to be explained
in a way that it doesn't overwhelm.
Short term learning explains like why,
uh,
checking your phone or visiting the
Internet while you're learning or even
engage in like a heavy thought
process, you know, it doesn't work.
Also explains why slides, you
know, like these, you know,
we should aim to have them,
you know, very clean, right?
Cause they don't overwhelm
short term memory.
The other side of short term
memory, his long term memory, right?
So you process information goes into long
term memory and long term memory works
basically on knowledge, right?
It works on, on context,
on what researchers call schemas. And this
is important for, for learning, right?
Because there's this debate and learning
like whether or not you should be able,
you should learn any sort of facts. If we
can Google all the facts, right? So if,
you know, Wikipedia allows
all the information to be
free, should we, you know,
learn any,
any facts and longterm memory makes it
very clear that facts are incredibly
important. You're my example
on this is, you know,
I can say I haven't seen or heard
Morgan get flushed it right now.
You can immediately look all those
German words up on your phone,
but it's very hard to actually make
sense of them to really fluently speak in
another language unless you have
that basic knowledge of affects.
So really it's important that we start
thinking about facts as he sort of basic
building blocks of, of memory, right?
But they are ways for us to engage.
And really one of the best predictors of,
you know, can you be better at physics,
is your knowledge of physics.
The best way to become better at
chemistry is simply raw knowledge about,
about chemistry. You know,
when we think about memory,
there's an another concept
that becomes really important.
And that's this idea of spacing.
This is an idea that dates
back to the 19th century.
And basically we forget,
we all forget at a very regular rate
and we often forget about how much we
forget. And so there's something
called the spacing curve. Uh,
my quiz on this is sort of,
you know,
how much of this specific talk do you
think you're going to remember tomorrow?
25% 50% 75% so, sir, I'm going to ask you,
what do you think tomorrow,
24 hours after this talk,
I asked you retrieval practice, you
know, wasn't mentioned in the talk.
And what do you think is the likelihood
that you'll, you'll recall it?
What's that?
A reasonable likelihood.
So reasonable likelihood
to me sounds like 50%. Uh,
so that is the correct answer.
What's frankly hard, right?
Is that I'm up here and I know that
by tomorrow you're gonna forget 50%.
If you don't revisit anything of
it within a week, it's gone. Right?
So my favorite example of this
is a guy named Roger Roger Craig.
He comes across the spacing research
idea that we forget a very regular rate.
Um,
this was about 10 years ago and he
started creating his own software,
then eventually uses some online
software to revisit ideas at the rate of
forgetting, right? Sort of
right at the edge of this curve.
We know when we're going to forget
something and if we revisit that item,
we're going to remember it for,
for longer.
So Roger Craig first develops
the software himself,
then eventually uses an online
software called [inaudible],
which is fantastic if you
haven't ever used it for this
type of, of, of knowledge.
And what happens is he
goes, uh, and, and the,
the thing about Roger Craig is key to
this story is that he loves games, right?
He loves baseball,
football,
and he watched jeopardy growing up
with his parents who he was like,
I'm going to use the science of
learning to get better at jeopardy.
Roger Keg goes on a jeopardy for his
very first time. He goes to Los Angeles,
you know,
he's there with Alex Trebeck.
He does so well on his very first time
that he wins the record for the first day
amount of,
of winnings on that.
He did so well that when he went home and
was like in his hotel room that night,
he was like, they're never
going to call me back. Right?
Like I did so well on these types of
recalling of facts that he was like,
they're just not going to have me on
now. Uh, Roger Craig has gone back on.
He's competed against Ken Jennings and
his sort of one of the top jeopardy
champs.
Uh,
and it is really just using the spacing
effect to revisit knowledge at this
point of time. And it's really
incredibly powerful, right?
And it doesn't really take huge
intervention. So in my family now,
we don't do homework on,
on Wednesday night, right?
One thing you can do to space
out learning more, right? Is to,
instead of doing a homework, my kids
usually have homework on Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, you know, take that
Wednesday slided into Sunday, right?
This is this key idea of just
spacing out that learning,
allowing for that inevitable.
Forgetting a,
now I'm going to admit that this is
not made me more popular as a parent.
It's sort of like causes dips
in my, my dad's stock, right?
But I tell my kids like,
you're just actually going to learn more
and it's the same amount of time you've
spent studying, but you're going to
retain it for a lot more from this,
this spacing effect.
So Roger Craig himself will admit to
anyone who speaks to him that like knowing
the answer of who wrote the bridge on the
river Kwai isn't real learning. Right.
It was just sort of a fact that allowed
him to do really well on, on jeopardy.
Then the question is sort of like
what really is expertise, right?
Whether this is what is like mastery
and how do we really wanted to learn it.
I got really interested in ID and there's
a bunch of really fascinating research
on this and that, you know, mastery really
knowing something is analogies, right?
It's your ability to think
through and in systems.
So I don't know if any of you ever
listened to the, the car talk a show,
but it's basically like two goofy guys
and people call in and say, you know,
I have a Buick and there's
like white smoke coming out,
had a little audio clip of it.
But it basically,
it's a colon show for car problems.
And if you,
if you listen to the show carefully,
what they do is, is crazy, right?
They've never seen this. Some calls in,
they've never met that person before,
right? They don't know if
they're a reckless driver.
They don't even know if there
were student or a senior citizen.
They've never seen the car before.
Right? So they don't know like, uh,
does it look dingy? They've never
sort of seen what the problem is.
And yet they're able to diagnose these
problems, you know, time. And again,
so the question then is like,
how do they do it? Right?
They do it through analogies,
right?
If someone calls in with a a Buick and
they're saying it has white smoke, right?
They're going through their own
mental model saying, Oh, you know,
have I ever worked on Buicks before?
What's the sign of white smoke? You know,
how does this,
uh,
how does this match up with
other experiences that we
have? And so, you know,
when we think about sort of learning
and we think about, you know,
what we ultimately want to do with what
we learn is to apply it in new ways.
Making sure that you learn in a
systems approach that you learn through
analogies that you're thinking about.
Compare and contrast is really,
really crucial. So researchers have
found this in topics like, you know,
math.
Uh,
this is also explains the idea of
the deep versus surface features,
uh, been able to show it in, in history.
And I got kind of excited about the
idea and was like, oh, we don't,
I'm going to take a wine class. Don't
know that much about wine. You know,
if you think about wine as analogies,
I should take a wine pairing class.
And what was remarkable to me
was that the pairings, right,
did give me a much richer sense
of wine. Right? So going in,
understood and was presented to me,
you know,
how did the tenants
relate to, uh, you know,
or why exactly does sort of a fatty
cheese reduced the sort of tendons that
you'd find in a lot of red wines?
You know, why do, uh, you know, uh,
sweet wines like a converted from ina,
like go well with
spicy food,
right?
But this is different than a lot of the
ways that we would usually engage with
sort of, you know, uh, wine, right? I
think a lot of people would be like, oh,
I need to figure out like,
what is a Pinot Noir?
Whereas the verts demeanor grown when,
if you really want to use that
information and use it in new ways, right?
You have to engage in sort of,
you know, what are the patterns.
Another example of this is, um,
uh, so the history example, uh,
that I prefer is a, you know, let's say
you want to learn about sort of war.
You want to learn about
World War II. Uh, you know,
you can think about sort of why did
the Germans winning World War Two,
one of the reasons red, the blitz
creek, you know, by definition,
the lightening attack was all about speed,
right?
And then you can start thinking about
like, why does speed help in wars? Right?
One of the reasons that the Americans
lost the war in Vietnam was, you know,
because of a lack of speed on the
other side, right? The Americans won,
uh, the revolutionary war, you know,
largely through, through speed.
And when you start thinking of,
you know,
topics in this way and making sure that
you learn in this way, it makes for much,
you know, a a richer sense
of, of learning. I, um,
ended up spending some time
with, uh, uh, er doctor at USF,
uh, and he's sort of a real expert on,
on problem solving, right? This is his,
his thing. And I watched him, uh, this
was at a medical school conference,
but someone brought in a, uh, a case,
uh, and it was a rare case, you know,
as a man spitting up blood and he
gave some advice around, you know,
what is good problem solving.
So, you know, one thing that
he said, uh, was, you know,
you need a one sentence
description of the issue, right?
And you want it something that
you're able to, to Google, right?
Another bit of advice I thought was great,
right?
Is that you need to update your
background knowledge, right?
So to go visit the Wikipedia site, right?
Make sure your, your deep knowledge is,
uh, your, your longterm
memories is rich enough. No.
But the other thing that
ultimately is problem solving,
at least in this medical context,
and really when you think about it,
any form of problem saw me. It's
form of pattern recognition, right?
So he has in his mind different kinds
of scripts, mental models of diseases.
And he is trying to match
that information, right?
Basically go form of analogical thinking
to match that information, right,
with the information, uh, of the
patient that's in front of him.
So we're going to go to the sort of
final, uh, lesson as it were. And,
and you know, what then becomes
really important is the process of,
of revealing, of reflecting,
of revisiting. Um, so
here's, uh, you know, uh, uh,
another quiz question for us. Uh, and the
question is, you know, should a speaker,
whether it's me or an educator,
how long the pause should they give in
a speech to allow people to a dwell on a
big idea, right? So should
they leave one second,
two seconds or more than three seconds.
So how long should the pauses be when a
speaker is asking an important question?
One second, two seconds or more than three
seconds. So I'm not asking you what do,
what do you think? No,
here in the front. Um,
okay, we're going to go to
someone else with the glasses. Uh,
went in three seconds.
Let's just say that the research study
dates back to the 1980s is actually
between three to five seconds. What's
remarkable is that three, five,
six is actually a pretty long time.
Now I give this presentation a lot
and I talk about this quiz item,
but I actually like don't even know
bay by the research itself, right?
Like I have not weighed in three to
five seconds. Uh, though I should have,
because you know, for the presenter it's
actually kind of uncomfortable, right?
It's like a good chunk of time.
But when you look at really good speakers,
speakers are very much better than me.
Like Barack Obama.
I mean if you watch him like he speaks
so slowly and the idea there is just
people need time to
digest this information.
Now at first glance it seems
like it's about working memory.
And to a degree it is. But there's
another thing happening here and that is,
you know, we often think that our thoughts
and our emotions are separate, right?
Or that our body and and reason
are separate, but the, they're,
they're very connected, right? And
so we need time to, to reflect.
So another way to think about this is,
you know,
I had two cell phones and they're
the same cell phone. This is a, uh,
uh, a nice study that was done once
and I give one of them the finger,
all right?
And then I wave at the same
other cell phone, right?
I will think that the first cell phone,
even though it's the same cell phone,
is a much worst cell phone,
right?
And so what happens is my hand giving my
phone the finger, it did the thinking,
right?
My hand did the thinking and then I use
that thinking right and engage in it.
So this is an incredible thing when
you, when you think about it, right?
Like our hands aren't supposed to think,
our bodies aren't supposed to, you know,
change the way that, that we, you
know, reasoning in this way and yet,
and yet they do. And this explains
you and I think, you know,
they're in other contexts,
we kind of know this idea like,
so in the creativity space, and people
love to talk about that. Like, you know,
you're in the shower and you have that
moment of recognition, but we need them.
The same thing in the, in
the learning space, right?
We need these times to reflect,
right?
We need these times to a process,
this information and allow in many ways,
right? Our emotions to become
attached to them. You know,
the other aspect of reflection, I
mean, and we can do this ourselves,
this form of reflection, right?
So some of it explains, you know,
why we want safety when we're learning,
right?
We see this as really
important in schools. There's
also explains why sort of,
you know, moments of solitude or it can
be really important for learning, right?
It also explains, um, you know,
w w w
why just even writing about something
is a very powerful way to learn.
And we see,
you know,
experts who really like hone on
getting better at their craft.
So Pat Metheny is a famous jazz guitarist.
Some of you might be familiar with him,
you know, really one of the world's best.
And after every concert,
he'll just spend a good chunk of
time just writing about what worked,
what didn't work, engaging in this,
in this type of reflection. I'm,
the other thing about this
type of reflection is that
it also allows us to check
our work. Right now this allows us to, uh,
engage in kind of the metacognition and
make sure that we're, you know, not,
not too confident. You know, what's
weird about kind of giving this,
this type of talk is that,
you know,
the messages that they often really boil
down to are not ones that I think many
people want to, right? So why
don't we does that. Learning
isn't really fun, right?
And when you see a lot of gains that
promise you can like learn secretly,
uh, that, you know, learning is
going to be fun. And you know,
the research actually suggests that
it's the other way around, right?
So one of the reasons that interleaving
is in a powerful way to learn is that it
actually makes learning a little bit
harder. And I think an alternative way to,
to think about this.
This was a math professor at Princeton
and I was talking with him and he was
like, yeah, you know, students today,
ours is saying, you know, learning is fun.
The much better way to thinking about
it is that learning or math is fun and
that's what makes it hard.
Excuse me.
Math is hard and that's what makes it fun,
right?
So that you're engaging in these
types of difficulties is actually,
you know, what, what makes
it enjoyable and you know,
to give other examples of the way that
this type of like active sort of harder
processing, right? It's also just so easy
to slip in these more comfortable ways.
Right? Whether we're using
highlighters or, or rereading.
I had this experience myself a few weeks
ago where I was like preparing for a
talk and I like had my notes
in front of me and you know,
I was just like, I really wanted
these notes and I kept, you know,
basically rereading them and they
were uncomfortable to me. Right.
It was like a topic I hadn't spoken about
a lot and it was really the opposite
of sort of better learning. Right.
I'm much better off, you know,
putting the material away and
engaging in that way. Right?
A another way to think about
this as sort of repeat backs,
sort of a management tool, but it's
essentially a form of active learning.
You know, I've done it. Um, now often
you know, with, with my wife, right?
Is that if you give someone some
instructions and if they're, you know,
more complicated instructions,
you want them to repeat that
information back to you, right?
That's another way of sort
of engaging this a form of,
of active learning. I think, you
know, the other thing that sort of,
this key theme here is zip forgetting
can really be your friend, right?
We often think that forgetting works
against us, right? But you know,
forgetting actually allows us
new forms of perspective, right?
It allows us to engage
in more systems thinking.
The key thing to also
understand about forgetting,
and this is a weird concept to understand,
is that you actually don't really forget,
there's some fun studies on this is
that if I go to you and say, you know,
can you remember your
high school locker number?
I think most people would be
like, Nah, I can't remember that.
But if I show you four digits, right? Or
excuse me, four options. And of those,
you know,
one of them is your high school locker
number for more than a one might guess.
And certainly a lot more than average.
You're actually able to, to, uh,
identify that number. So the question is,
if you are able to remember everything,
you know, how, how do you
actually remember something
and turns out, right? It's,
it's the retrieval, it's pulling
things out of memory, right?
Is that makes them more available,
right?
And this explains why these
more active types of learning,
whether explaining to yourself or
explaining it to someone else can be so
effective, right? They allow
you to see these types of
connections, but then again,
they allow you to have things
sort of a top of mine, right?
They allow you to exist to them.
And I guess my parting thought in
this regard is, you know, always,
always look for patterns, right? You know,
it's so easy to look for this
very specific bit of detail,
right? So if you're learning about oceans
as an example, right? You'd want to know,
okay, you know, what's the
temperature of the ocean, right?
But if you're engaging in these types
of analogies, you're starting to think,
or this types of systems thinking,
you're going to say to yourself, okay,
what happens when the water
temperature goes up? Right?
One of the things that happens
is more vapor is produced.
This helps us understand why climate
change can be so dangerous, right?
To some of the storms or more a terrible,
but this also helps us then understand
why sea levels are rising, right?
Because the relationship between heat
and water is such that, you know,
water expands as it grows.
Bigger analogies though are difficult,
right? And when you're using analogies
using this type of, of systems thinking,
you want to have analogies
that you know well, right?
So the analogy of like it cuts like a
knife works because we're all pretty
familiar with knives and
analogies in this same regard,
is that if you're explaining
an idea to someone else, right?
Sort of like you want Uber for
kindergarten or Uber for cooking, right?
You're using an analogy that,
that all of us are familiar with.
And then the reverse side is that,
you know,
these analogies that don't work are either
sort of quiz problems or they're just
playing the funny, and I'll leave you
with that thought, which is, you know,
what is, uh, you know, Barack Obama
and Mount Kilimanjaro have in common,
you know, it turns out to
be Africa. So with that,
I'm going to thank you again for taking
the time to come out here today and
listen to this,
and thank you again.
[inaudible].